greetings apiece welcome to the D show
very exciting topic with exciting guest
who was on the def jam now Def Jam was
started by Russell Simmons if you didn't
know for those people who are really
into music and I believe jay-z was one
of the presidents
so Musiq Soulchild if you heard of them
I haven't but they're associated with
Def Jam along with neo and he was
working with the likes of Tyrese Gibson
he's no stranger to the Dean show I've
done in many shows revolving around him
keep Keyshia Cole he worked with her
Bruno Mars these are some big names in
the music industry
so we're going to be talking about this
topic how music has an effect on not
only the mind body and soul amongst
other things with an expert in this area
who was on the Def Jam record label when
we come back here in the Dean show don't
go anywhere
this is the this is the video this is
the days of the theme this is the theme
it is a quiche welcome to the dino
salaam-alaikum so now I'm gonna have to
lay over Kathy Umar aka how do you
pronounce la blah la bones L Dubois L
Dubois L Dubois is French yeah the boys
crazy but you were singing R&B French
songs no no I was going on being English
in English now what our army is like
with the romanticise like get the honey
get all the money and yeah yeah I mean
you sing them with the sweet nothings
right the love songs and you know trying
to get a woman like you say a lot of
those type of songs you know yeah that's
what it's associate now some of these
names these are big names associated
with Def Jam is that like that's a
really huge record label yeah Def Jam is
a very well-known record label the top
isn't it was yes yes especially it was
very well known in regards to especially
dealing with hip hop back in the days
you know people like Run DMC all of
these people were on Def Jam LL Cool J
these people all of these a Def Jam
artists that was my general joj yeah he
had some clean songs back I don't say
yes that later but he had some clean
Denis yeah yes yeah listo what about
Musiq Soulchild
what they're also a big-name group Musiq
Soulchild is actually an artist he's a
singer-songwriter like myself formerly
he's somebody that's well known among
the youth so he's def jam artists also
yeah real Jam artist Neal neo is another
former he's a he's a singer-songwriter
musician right now that a lot of people
are familiar with neo I never met neo
myself but he's somebody that has been
associated with Def Jam now you worked
also alongside with
Keyshia Cole yeah they were you know man
Keyshia Cole we did a few writing
sessions before she actually became you
know well-known there in industry I
worked with her I've done writing
sessions with Tyrese when the same
Studios working together so many people
you know Raphael the likes of Raphael
Saadiq a lot of people are familiar with
him I've worked with him several times
you know these a lot of people a lot of
these people are good people but you
know just need the guidance of this land
many of people needed guidance of Islam
Bruno Mars
who's Bruno Mars is he's an artist same
thing singer-songwriter musician who was
very well-known who knows the Italian
Bruno you know that's a good question
you know boon I think he's mixed so he's
a very very nice guy you know me and him
had the opportunity to perform on the
same stage 'as and you know very nice
guys ER be also yeah wannabe style he's
doing some different stuff right now you
know that uh that is going back you know
to like the prince days you know stuff
like that he's been doing lately now you
were signed with this record label yes
right was silent Island Def Jam for
about two and a half three years yeah
now many I mean this is what many people
aspire they want to be a star they see
many of these stars of dirty celebrities
and now they dream of this they go to
sleep you know listening to music
watching the music musicians up there
and they would just sell their souls and
many do you know just trying to get up
there and how was it you able to leave
this lifestyle you know it's really that
he is a mercy from Allah to Allah
because after I got off of Def Jam I
began to do stuff independently and I
think probably that next year I got
signed to BMG Music for songwriting I
was doing commercials with a
agency called vowels artists management
out of New York I was doing many things
on my own and so I started to do going
meetings in order to get you know some
more exposures to get onto another
record label maybe 13 meetings but a lot
Allah kept me from that and so then I
went on to do things independently and
subhanAllah just before you know really
launching out there because by that time
I had fans in Australia on my own London
different areas so but right before
actually launching out there really
really getting out there a lot to how to
save me from that and bless me with it's
not yeah and so I I didn't feel
comfortable anymore with doing what
speaking about certain things that were
going against what a lot revealed you
know speaking about zina and all of
these different things I wanted to get
away from that along with the
environment which will touch down on
some more inshallah before we go to
break so what's the typical day like for
it depends I said it depends I mean you
have different types of people you have
a person I usually say you have three
different types of musicians or three
different types of individuals that deal
with music you have a person that's like
becomes like a complete introvert you
have one that that becomes addicted to
women and do you have one that's
addicted to drugs and alcohol or do you
have you can add a fourth category we
have one that's like a mixture of them
all you understand so it's that you have
different types of personalities
nobody's the same so in all of these
areas are dangerous they're very
dangerous and I maybe was type of person
that could possibly associated with
least two of those categories I never
did drugs and alcohol these type of
things but I didn't like to go out too
much and these type of things it but you
see that all of any one of those things
really had effects on people really had
effects on each and every one of those
people that you see doing it there they
fit one of those categories you know
yeah we're going to talk about some more
of different people that you've known
that went down this course and it seems
like you know the world just opens up to
you and you would think you'd be very
happy but I
many people end up becoming very
disparate we're going to be talking with
you on the effects of the music that has
on the heart mind body and soul here -
Dean show with former Def Jam artists
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show entertainment seems
like your turn on the TV someone turns
onto TV you know all this entertainment
entertaining us and many of times or
most of the time people are forgetting
that we have a purpose in this life we
just haven't been created for play and
horsing around you know is a time and
place but you got serious with life you
figured out what the purpose of life is
you living it compared your heart to
back then to now how does it feel
bismillah at Harley level salat WA Salam
o Rasul Allah and that's something that
we I need to start with because that
gives me that that is especially with
the question you just asked me you know
what is the difference now difference
now versus that that's what you want to
know about right you know the thing is
Eddie when you when you go out and
you're doing all of those things as you
experience yourself many times you spoke
about these things you start to ask
yourself what is the purpose of life you
ask yourself what is the purpose of life
and I literally that he I used to have
these conversations with many of my
friends after going out of these things
many of them are musicians just like
myself we would we would next day acts
each other what was the purpose of that
does that matter now the all of that we
did last night does it matter now and
the answer was no it didn't matter now
we were questioning what is the true
purpose of life and this is something
that people didn't want to ponder on
especially the people that I was around
a lot of people try to get around this
question because if you ask yourself
that question then you have to face what
the the question of
you have to face the reality of death
that soon you're going to die and what
happens then so soon after I began
questioning questioning and I ran across
some brothers that were one of my
friends actually took Shahada before me
and we we set up speaking about the
purpose of life and I was given the
Koran and four months this Quran was
sitting on my shelf literally four
months for a long time and I regret that
now because maybe you know I would have
would have got the chance to enter this
land much sooner but I read before that
he gave me a book that was called the
SEO in the gym by dr. bilal philips this
was the translation that he did by evan
taymiyah essay on the gym and he knew
that I was into things dealing with the
unseen so I read this and it absolutely
blew me away because I never read
anything like that and then after that
this is when I got a chance to read the
Quran now keep in mind at this time I
have read so much different material I
was somebody that really was in search
of the truth you can ask anyone that was
around me at the time I will read all
different types of book books on
Buddhism Taoism Confucianism dealing
with as I'm I was raised born and raised
as a you know raised as a Christian in a
Christian home as a Baptist so I have
read the Bible you know of course you
read in the Old Testament so you're
dealing with the Torah and but nothing
really resonated in the heart except
that I saw that Jesus peace be upon him
and all of the prophets were praying and
prostrating to one creator so it was a
time in my life I remember being you
know in my early 20s and I want to be
like then I don't know
you know what way of life teaches that
but I want to be like them and that's
when I realized that my family was doing
something opposite from what was you
know what they were taught so this is
what led me to that path of truth so
when I read the Quran bring that back to
there when I read the Quran this was
something that was absolutely amazing
this was something that was speaking
about all of those prophets that I have
read about before worshiping one creator
you know
not worshiping the creation and that's
something that everybody knows in their
heart that what they're supposed to be
doing is worshiping the Creator
everybody knows that in the heart when
they're born as we know that with the
prophets on some mentions that every
child is born on the fictional every
child is born upon worship knowing
knowing that they're supposed to worship
Allah and a lot alone one God and one
God alone without worshiping anything
besides him so this was the absolute
truth to me when I saw this that all of
these prophets from Jesus Moses Sodom
and David and the latter than the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him while worshiping one creator
and I felt like the Quran was something
that spoke directly to me
it wasn't telling me you know that
such-and-such said this and he didn't
give me that gave me the impression that
someone sitting in the tree telling me a
story in the third person rather even
when the creator of the heavens and the
earth would narrate something it was
coming from him and I would literally
play games with a crime and he opened up
to a random page and it's speaking about
the things that I personally was dealing
with and this is something that anybody
can do I challenge anyone just open the
Quran up open it up and and see it
addressing your issues right there it's
amazing how you we know that people go
to sleep to music they wake up to music
in the car music and it seems their
whole life revolves around the next hit
song coming out but then you know that's
a big hide and I have a steep low how do
you how do you how did you feel like
music was having an influence on your
heart mind body and soul so pound on my
brother literally when I started to make
solo you just have a feeling in your
heart and I had the same conversation
with a few other brothers that
experienced the same thing as me the
thing is is that when you start to make
solo you feel like you're mixing
something something that is you know an
hour and I'm and I'm not ashamed am i
sha to say something that is evil or
something that is pure it seems like
you're trying to mix the two and this
brings us back to the the statement of
I am Joe Zia when he mentioned that you
know the the no one can have the Koran
and music in that heart at the same time
they can't mix with one another I
experienced these things being a
musician that's different from a person
that just listens to music being a
musician you're experiencing the effects
I used to play my guitar for eight hours
a day
Eddy as I mentioned to you sometimes
will fall asleep with Mike or with it
with it with the guitar in my hand so in
playing piano I play piano guitar
harmonica play various different
instruments
you know bass guitar just to you know
you want to get feel the different
vibration in the vet that develops
different sound
you're like a one-man band yeah it was
that was exactly me I mean that was that
was when I was in the studio was just me
playing everything doing everything
doing the background vocals doing
everything anyone who knows me who knew
me in the past will attest to that you
know so the effects of it so somebody
you talking about feeling the effects
this was the plan of a love me they feel
those effects of this and to be able to
I believe to be able to warn people
against it because it's something many
people talk about the difference of
opinion and things like this I guarantee
you you speak to a former musician and
you bring anyone that may have that
opinion if I'm a musician may be able to
change the mind of their chef you start
to shake I start to reflect because I
had conversations I've had conversations
with a few that may have held that
position and their mind is as you know
thinking you know should I change my
position now because of the things that
you're able to express to them it's not
a game it's extremely dangerous and you
were I mean you lived it eight hours a
day playing all of these whenever you
are sad Eddie you want to turn to the
music to make you feel better many
musicians former musicians like myself
had the same experience when you you
know and that's and we know as when you
feeling sad which we should you turn to
the book of a lie you should be turning
to the crime for that for that remedy
for that cure but rather we return it to
the music and what this was doing it
gives you it gives you that
temporary field it gives you a temporary
pleasure where's the Koran it continues
to feed you in the proper way you know
it continues to feed you people don't
realize that the club isn't is also a
place of worship for people that listen
to music it has a place we can go out
and go deep into the I've pondered on
these talking about the nightclub the
night we got the the music is the Quran
for the Shaitaan yeah right so they
listening to us let's give it a new one
I like this now now the Masjid is a
place of worship for the Muslims and
that's for the Muslim but I mean for for
the people of the nightclub as a place
of worship us like we're going to talk
more about as we come back here in India
a very exciting show
former Def Jam artist don't go anywhere
right back please subscribe to the DJ
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show former Def Jam
artist so instead of turning to the book
that was revealed from the crater the
heavens and earth it's the Koran temper
free tamper-proof it's a living miracle
and it gives that joy that contentment
that peace to the heart now people they
turn into the music trying to fill of
empty void doesn't work and then now we
left off talk about people also because
was a tribute of music you have we go to
the house of worship a must you the
people going to the to the to the
nightclubs and performing some ritual
acts of worship there talk about this
Sohan along I mean it's the thing that
people don't realize you have a place of
worship where the people that want to
worship the creator of the heavens and
earth they go to to recite the Quran and
not this is not the only place people go
to the recite the Quran but it's known
as one of the places when you're going
inside of the house of Allah you see
people you can see you can go to areas
in and it's buzzing like bees you know
people are reciting the Quran reciting
the Quran and so you see this is a place
of worship you know for people that want
to worship the Creator then you have
those who not unknowingly
are worshiping the Shaitaan
because you have a this is and it has
its place of worship in this place is
the nightclubs you know you have just
listen if you were to turn off the music
alone and just hear about what what
people are talking about in the songs
it's always 99% of the time leading to
the disobedience of Allah the
disobedience of the creator of the
heavens and earth you're talking about
Xena we we don't need to go into it I
don't know what it's talking about if
people if the music was shut off half of
this stuff people would listen to it so
the music is added for that for that
effect that you know that takes a person
in a you know in a trance and hypnotic
trance you know even scientists know
that music has a as effect on you that
that is very hypnotic you know I know
there's as a former musician it's
something that's very hypnotic so you
may listen to something that you
wouldn't normally listen to without that
music in it you know people people say
oh well you know as long as the lyrics
are fine you know people don't realize
the effects of you know even something
like jazz you know you're talking about
instrumentation it has effects on the
heart and it may be that you must you
may cause so much damage to your heart
that when you read the Quran it won't
have any effect on them
people need to reflect on something
right and I don't want to go too much
too deep because I know the time is
limited reflect on this like the Quran
music can be recited it can be listened
to and it could be written down people
don't think about that like why the
Quran can be recited listened to and it
can be written down there are at war in
the hearts of the people you understand
there's no there's no doubt about who
would win that there's no competition
you talk about music versus the Quran
one causes one effect and another causes
another effect the Quran brings pleasure
to the hearts just look at I always
always I always tell people to ponder on
this just
got how people die a lot of times that
are addicted to music and are addicted
to which takes them too many times
addicted to alcohol and drugs and things
look at the past look at some of the
most well-known musicians how what was
their end
how did they die you know how did they
die and it's very important to examine
it and then you look at the type the top
reciters how did they die many of them
dying in the most peaceful state you
know which which which is very important
you know that's a very important ayah
from Allah
you know seeing how people die you know
they're so now I mean when you put this
into perspective you know that there are
many things distracting us from really
reflecting contemplating why we're here
as I mentioned earlier and now that
you've connected and you are charging
your heart because we've charged the
cell phone the iPad and now was this
just a temporary fix where people would
be listening to music and that quickly
wears off you're in the same position it
was an audition again when you charge
the heart with what it's supposed to be
charged with with the remembrance
salutely of God because Julian
remembrance of God is God says in the
Quran do hearts find rest did you find
this this tranquility beautiful honest
and that's a big difference you know
when I was you know when I was sick when
I was sad many times or not feeling not
feeling right you I used to pick up my
guitar play the piano to start feeling a
certain way now I immediately go to the
Quran or I perform to rock out so you
you you it's a different it's a whole
different thing you're dealing with a
whole different level of tranquility and
I encourage any brother or sister that I
that are dealing with this struggle of
music you know just go a day or two
without listening to a challenge
yourself challenge yourself gonna when I
embrace Islam if one of the first things
I did and you talking about of forming
musician so no one can't tell me how
hard it is you understand how difficult
it is about no one can tell me about the
difficulty I went the whole of Ramadan
without listen to music because Ramadan
was about two months later when I
embrace Islam so I went that whole
Ramadan when I listen to music and I
felt as if
didn't need it anymore you know and I
have dealt with some trials after
Ramadan until later giving it up now
it's been about six almost six years or
so since I played a guitar any
instrument it's been about six years now
hum did enough since I've completely
left the music industry itself so I
encourage brothers and sisters to start
to pick up the Quran even if you're
reading a verse a day two verses start
five minutes start small and build up
you know give it give the Quran its
rights don't just leave it on the shelf
to to collect us and then take it down
for Ramadan and and and we read the
Quran but rather we should be reading
reflecting reading in tough you know
reflecting upon the taxi and going to
books of Tessier you know there's many
books have shared in English for even
English reader to to read now before we
leave we've seen another television
program you did and when we talk about
music we're not talking about the
natural sound of birds and the bees and
the beautiful human voice we're talking
about you know the culture today that's
surrounded by audio pornography that
calls you to fornication to drugs to
illicit sexual intercourse and all these
evil things that if you turned it off
these beats and all the stuff that's
just lowering you in you most people
would be appalled but now you've also
done some some machine where it's your
voice can you leave us with could you
leave our audience with something of
maybe fifteen seconds awesome would you
mind if I recited court huh yes it's not
that be beautiful yes I will be Limina
shade wanna muddy
bismillah your merry way
M de barranca la vie be a Telugu Iguala
cliche in kadhi
Neil and Levy colic on Malta 1 hey
Italia become a ukume us and Ramallah
one Aziz gluten
oh la vie koala Cozumel urgent we become
matter of evil Kira many beautiful Faro
de bas Ora altrimenti
I'm the marshal Arthur bucco thank you
so much for that wonderful recitation
that was the verbatim Word of God the
qu'ran that anyone even if they didn't
understand it connects with the heart
thank you for sharing your experiences
with us
inshallah God willing we can have you
back again on this show Luba and she'll
be happy and leave the honor to come
back here thank you thank you salaam
aleikum walekum salam when I delayed
with a catch
and from working with the likes of
Keyshia Cole Bruno Mars Def Jam Russell
Simmons now to being on the D show
reciting the verbatim would have God
took her and and truly in the
remembrance of God do hearts find rest
connect with the Quran it's been sent as
a mercy to the world and the purpose of
life is mentioned in there why you've
been created as mentioned in there and
where you're going when you die it's all
mentioned in there so now you can sit
back you can keep listening to these
these nasty lullabies that are out there
putting you to sleep
calling you to all sorts of things that
just corrupt your heart mind body and
soul or you can purify it you can charge
up the heart give it back to the one who
created it and you have that peace of
contentment
so benefit from the advice that we gave
here today subscribe if you haven't
already you can follow us now on the
Twitter and the Facebook also on the
Instagram we'll see you next time
Hannity show God well until then peace
be with you please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below